what's up my man hey Rich welcome back
first and foremost thanks buddy
yeah I just want to uh the world's on
fire huh the world is on fire
it's global warming it's global warming
that's what they say what do you think
about all that
I think that it's uh pretty interesting
that an island has got a lack of water
to put out uh fires as in I think that's
uh
and they had apparently the best alarm
system on the planet as well that they
just chose not to uh ring so all of that
but hey it's global warming that's doing
it yeah I'll say this I mean when I was
on Sardinia they had two of the
Bombardier water bombers there at the
airport and they had some fires going on
there as well too
um
people don't know this about me but I
used to work for the ministry of Natural
Resources for a summer when I was 16
they had this program called the junior
Ranger program and what they did was
they took a bunch of 16 year olds up
north to Northern Ontario uh mostly our
parents didn't want to deal with it so
they stuck us on a train at Union
Station downtown Toronto we went up to
full yet Ontario and then they took us
to another town called chaplo and all
around there there's uh tree planting uh
taking weevils out of trees clearing
Portage Trails we did all the [__] for
the government basically for minimum
wage and we were learning about forestry
and forest fires because that was one of
the areas that we had to deal with there
was a couple of forest fires that we had
to get some piss packs they had these
squirt packs so you'd fill them with
water and you basically squirt them like
this and you deal with ground fires with
them so we had a little bit of a
training session and we learned that
there's really only three sources of uh
forest fire so the stuff that you guys
see today it only comes from three
places lightning strikes uh Sparks that
come off of
um improperly maintained or aligned uh
Rail lines or tracks on uh trains or
human negligence
and human negligence doesn't cause that
many forest fires there's there's the
odd new guy that that goes out camping
he's a bit of a [__] and he doesn't
know how to put out a fire sort of thing
but most people that are outdoorsmen and
they go out they they generally care
about you know the environment putting
out fires properly so it's it's mostly
lightning strikes that cause most forest
fires and I'll tell you something I was
scrolling through Twitter like a couple
months ago actually this is more towards
the spring when the Quebec forest fires
were really ripping it out and I think
Casey neistat put a video out
um about New York City and like the
skyline was all orange and you couldn't
see like you know your hand in front of
your face it was really bad he was you
know he's talking about all that and I
saw this uh satellite imagery over
Quebec on where all the fire started and
I'm actually surprised that they
released this because this told me
exactly what happened there was
something like 9 to 11 fires that all
started at the exact same time so it was
so it was time lapse video right so you
see like you know the ticker at the
bottom and you see smoke plumes
simultaneously in 11 different places in
Northern Quebec all start and then you
see them get caught in the winter they
sort of blow across the province right
not a single cloud in the sky okay so
that rules out lightning
what are the chances of trains Sparks
coming off mismanaged lines and and
tracks simultaneously in 11 different
locations starting those fires I'd say
almost nil and I would probably argue
that there is almost like no or or any
Rail lines near those areas so that so
that rules out lightning and it rules
out trains which means it's got to be
humans that started the fires right I've
never seen like the amount of fires that
we have burning in Canada right now that
we do this year in any other past year
which tells me they were started
intentionally that's what I think so
yeah why would they do that
it's to fear monger and it's to argue
for more Taxation and carbon taxes and
more taxes for this that and the other
thing because
um that's that's part of the global
agenda right like that's part of the you
know they tried the scandemic and that
worked for a few years right and it's
like okay we have to try to control
people with something new something more
scary something oh the world is on fire
because of global warming [__] it's
cold as [__] here in the summertime now
it's not even that warm
well how interesting that in 2020 was I
believe a worldwide low for uh forest
fires yeah interesting that during those
years everyone was uh made to be inside
in a way it was locked down yeah so
interesting where do you live by the way
in Calgary in Calgary so oh
so I mean you're probably pretty pretty
familiar with what I'm talking about
when it comes to fires and and Forestry
and stuff then oh 100 100 and and I'm
gonna dig into it as well but from my
understanding is that there was a
program where they would clear fuel
from the forests
um to make sure that there wasn't dead
branches light grass all of that that's
going to go up and they really scaled
back on that heavily so I think that's a
component to it uh yeah they usually
have controlled Burns
um to deal with dead brush and there's
some there's some Force Management in
that area but forest fires have always
happened right like it's it's a natural
part of
you know the world and and climate
changes right like climate has always
changed I don't think it's it should be
called climate change or global warming
climates change no right like 12 000 800
years ago we had a massive Ice Age and
you know there was a significant uh they
say meteor impact in different parts of
the world it probably broke up you know
the atmosphere and you know we've had
climate change various times throughout
history you know every every few
thousand you know years sometimes every
10 000 years we have dramatic changes
it's just this is just a random thing I
don't think it's like human involvement
or influence I think it's like they're
doing this on purpose to try to scare
[__] well yeah I mean uh how convenient
that um that's called Global boiling
apparently is that
the UN is calling it Global boiling now
is that a thing
I don't know about that particular
terminology
is that today in the National Post there
was a story about uh how literally it
says that uh the the planet is on fire
and that also it's connected to anxiety
throughout so talking about there's a
study done on children seeing smoke and
if they see smoke then that connects
them to a lot of different anxieties uh
problems with behavior all of this other
type of of nonsense so now that we're
saying the same
another reason to really keep people
afraid and scared stay inside again
because it's smoke right smoke don't
breathe it in so so it's so interesting
that it's it's creating the same effect
that we had of that little illness that
we had just recently yeah and a lot of
uh interesting little details are coming
out of that post this and then literally
they can't get creative enough to create
something that to make everyone feel
fearful they're literally just going to
be right on the face of it and say hey
the world's on fire now stay inside
I mean and it's global warming okay okay
like people are just getting more
gullible and stupid as time goes on and
uh I'm sorry guys I just don't have a
lot of patience for it like I understand
you know being cautious and paying
attention to some
media pieces that are broadcasted too
like I remember during the scandemic in
you know in the early months like let's
say it happened it was around January
February March that it really started to
ramp up in that year then it was by like
March it's like okay this is happening
now it's a pandemic wear masks stand on
your dots social distance okay fine you
know maybe this is a real thing right a
month or two goes by and I'm like you
know I'm concerned for my parents I'm
like look don't go anywhere we'll get
your groceries you know just just chill
out you know because they're older stuff
like that so and then I'm like hang on
if this is such a big thing and it's a
you know really that bad why do I not
know anybody that's sick or dying or
dead why does nobody that I know not
dead why is everybody you know doing
weird things like driving in a car with
their windows up wearing gloves and a
mask like
it just didn't start adding up but I
Remember by like April of that year I
put out a video it's on my entrepreneurs
and cars channels so I I think the title
of it was something like uh sheeple the
dot standing people because that's what
I saw I saw sheeple standing on dots and
it was like oh you know you got a social
distance like get away from me sort of
thing like they were wigging out sort of
stuff right and it's like wow we really
got everybody going in that direction
real quick everybody gave up on uh
autonomy on sovereignty on their own
self-con you know control and they you
know 75 of the population fell for it
right because about 75 got the Jabs some
people were forced to was like if you
don't do this and we're gonna fire you
sort of thing uh I know some people's
wives were like look I've done it you
need to do it you know to protect the
household and the guys like fine
whatever you know just do it yeah okay
so you see what I'm saying here right
like absolutely people people fall for
stuff all the time and uh I don't know
man I think humans are just gullible
right they were just a very gullible
species a very successful species but
we're also very gullible too yeah I
think this is a recent though right I
think that this kovitz
that illness
set an interesting standard right and it
was a great litmus test to see what
people will actually do and will succumb
to oh yeah and it's it's a pretty low
bar that we've gone so the fact that
we've got certain organizations
worldwide or organizations saying that
they want uh no one to own anything and
you'll be happy yeah and to control I
mean it's right out in front of us and
they're not hiding the situation how
interesting that these two occurrences
that mysterious illness that we had
um plus now these fires create the same
result in people to be fearful fully of
anxiety and say stay inside if you see
smoke
I mean
reason in regards to smoke that makes
however
this is all coming together for the same
result and when you've got certain
organizations
clearly stating that they don't want you
to own things any longer and prices are
being driven up at every
it doesn't take a lot to put the little
pieces together to see what's happening
yeah
so yeah it's a it is a crazy ass world
that is uh coming at us and um I'll be
honest with you guys I don't want to I I
just don't want a part of it you know I
want to play with super games I don't
want to I don't want to live in places
where they're going to pull [__] like
this and they and they can lock you down
and prevent you from leaving uh there's
absolutely no way that I'm gonna let
happen what happened a few years ago
happen again so it's like you know if
you see the writing on the wall like I
do you know take the appropriate steps
and make sure that you are in control of
your life you know it's as simple as
that that's right well I've got a young
son he's six so I'm not going and this
stuff makes me willing to fight is your
is your ex willing to like does she see
it from the same perspective that you do
or or she like about more like you know
comply scared of oh full flashlight
that absolutely
um
yeah that's one of the difficult things
when you're divorced right you know if
you like people don't like divorce can
be one of the best times of your life
ever and one of the shittiest times in
your life ever too right because like
you know you've got freedom and you got
your kids
um and if you did it right you're not
poor right but now you're anchored to
Calgary right because you've got a small
kid yeah and you know you can't take
your kid away from the mom you know it's
not allowed uh you know she technically
can't do the same to you so you got to
kind of stick it out and you have
conversations around like well does
Billy need that uh you know
uh experimental job that they're telling
us that we really need uh is he up to
date on all of his experimental jobs
that he needs to go to this grade of
school and you know this school because
that's how they enforce it on you right
like we never had that when I was a kid
no I never had any vaccinations when I
was a kid but now they have certain
vaccinations that are mandatory
um I'm I'm not too worried about them
because they're older ones and they're
the older Tech they're not the MRNA
[__] ones
um but they are enforcing more and more
on you and your families that we
ultimately had the freedom to just you
know decide and choose
um when we were younger
out now showing that mRNA does not leave
your body there's no removal from you
once that's in there so
um so that is something that we're
finding out now post that this is a big
issue and again this is what I'm going
to fight for and Rich you say I can't
leave where are you gonna go this is all
across the planet now it's across most
of the West yeah yeah some places that
are slightly better you know slightly
worse than others but it's like yeah and
and that's why when I'm you know looking
at this when people go like well where
are you gonna go it's like I don't know
that I'm gonna go anywhere permanently
to be honest with you because for me a
sailboat has a couple anchors you know
bound Stern and you can hang out in a
country for as long as you want if you
don't like it you can pull up your [__]
you can sail somewhere else right that's
one of the cool things that I like about
that so you can set up your tax
residency in a country you don't really
need to live in and spend most of your
time in that way so there's so there's
options right like there's there's
things that you can do when you you
start you know sort of digging into it
the thing that you that you have to
acknowledge that you can't
ignore is that if you want to have those
options though you have to have your
life structured in such a way that you
have the maneuverability right so
you know to a point like you and you
know for me even like my kid's a little
bit older but
inviting the right kind of person and
you know the right kind of woman in your
life I mean if you're gonna have
children with a woman
make better choices like I'm sure you as
I've come to acknowledge you know in my
own life could have done some better
vetting could have could have
acknowledged red flags as I saw them
um and avoided you know the life that
I've created you know for myself where I
can't leave right now either right like
I've got to figure out [__] over the
next years as I'm planning it and you
know
um it is what it is man but yeah that is
that is life we've covered a lot on this
with walburger well I think
solution to this or Elixir for it is a
conversation that you have I mean I've
listened to you for I don't know how
many hours been part of this as well and
having logical conversation with those
who are making decisions that seem to be
built on emotion
I've rarely seen someone step up and and
debate with you and not agreed in the
end with what you said
because with realistic situations so
that people have come on and talked to
you looking to be in opposition yet they
walk away in agreement so we need to do
that all the time but the thing is
people aren't willing to step up and
talk because some of this these things
that are being said are still ridiculous
conversations
I get it anyway
um I got a few other guys waiting but um
yeah it was good seeing you man we'll uh
catch up soon okay welcome back bro
everybody thanks I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out